welcome back our state has a new mrs
nevada america we are so excited to
welcome her to las vegas now may i
present to you mrs nevada america 2021
sarah van dam
or good afternoon how are you good
afternoon i'm doing well thank you so
much for having me today first off
congratulations how exciting have these
last couple days been or these last
couple weeks been for you they've been
very excited exciting and they've been
very very busy
uh we've had a lot of events already and
a lot more fundraisers and charity
events
coming up in the future so i want to
talk about some of those but first of
all let's talk a little bit about the
organization what does it mean to be in
mrs nevada america yeah that's funny
that you ask actually because i didn't
know this was my first pageant i didn't
know really what i was in for what i was
getting into i did it to
get out of my comfort zone more or less
than anything else but over the course
the past few months what i realized was
that
it is a charitable organization
so the core of mrs nevada america and
the mrs america system itself are really
connecting with the community and then
giving back to the community and that's
something that's really important to you
you can tell that
when you talk about your platform i
really like what you are standing for
and trying to do can you explain that a
little bit yeah my platform is called
keys to empowerment and what it is is
about helping women to achieve their
absolute highest potential and young
girls as well so i'm working closely
with girls on the run las vegas
which is a youth development program
that helps build confidence and
self-esteem and life skills for young
girls and i think you're a prime example
of what it is to to really own that like
you said you really just wanted to get
out of your comfort zone you never did a
pageant before and what a great example
you are to these young girls and and
women that have never done anything like
that well i appreciate that yeah and we
have a lot of work to do this year we
want to do as much good in the community
as we possibly can on a number of
friends women children let's talk about
some of those because you do have a
couple of really cool upcoming events
that that you're taking uh care of the
community with what what's going on yes
one of them that we have is uh i i'm a
former more
muay thai fighter and so that's near and
dear to my heart i love sharing it with
people
it's great for building self-confidence
self-esteem stress relief and in
conjunction with one kicks gym we're
going to be hosting an intro to women's
muay thai class and the proceeds from
that are actually going to be donated or
portion of them to girls on the run
another big event that we have coming up
is called paint it forward for
victoria's voice
and a portion of those proceeds are
going to go to victoria's voice which
raises awareness for drug addiction and
substance abuse and that will be at
pinot's palette in the district at green
valley ranch that sounds like so much
fun and the the muay thai too can you
show me how to throw up a product
they're a proper punch all right so you
gotta have you gotta have your guard
okay right and then it's this is a
other other are you right hand left hand
i'm right-handed okay so uh this will be
your basically your your jab okay
forward and then back okay always come
back and cover your face oh okay so oh
yeah i can't just go
defense is as important as often you are
so
talented all the way around check out
sarah's paint it forward event this is
going to be really cool for victoria's
voice october 17th at 1 pm pinos palette
in the district at green valley ranch
thank you so much and what a great
representative of the state that you are
we appreciate you thank you i appreciate
it